♪♪
-Come on, Kyle.
Our sketch was due an hour ago.
We need to turn it in now.
-No, it needs to be perfect.
I've got to keep writing.
-But we'll get in trouble.
They don't like it
when it's turned in late.
-I don't care
what anyone thinks.
I'm going to keep on writing
and I don't need to
listen to you,
you jealous [bleep]
-Hi. It's Jake Gyllenhaal.
Where's your sketch, Mooney?
-You say something to me
[bleep]?
-Arrgghh!
[ Dramatic music plays ]
-Drugs?
Are you addicted?
-So what, Donnie Dorko?
I need them to write.
Ah, no, what am I saying?
I have so many problems
and secrets.
-Well, we're here to listen,
Kyle.
-Yes, we want to know more about
your life and how you got here.
-Okay. Guess it's time for me
to get serious.
♪♪
Hey, Kyle Mooney here
and I can't wait to take you
behind the scenes of my new
weekly segment for "SNL,"
"Serious Night Live."
♪♪
I don't care what anyone thinks.
I'm going to keep on writing
and I don't need to
listen to you,
you jealous [bleep]
So, yeah, that was a fun one.
I love dramatic shows and movies
and I love "SNL,"
and I'm like,
"Can we combine them?"
That's never been done, right?
Let's go behind the scenes,
come on.
So "Serious Night Live" is the
new dramatic non-comedy series
I'm going to be doing every week
at the show.
-They don't like it
when it's turned in late.
-Yes! Great.
Sort of an A24 meets
Safdie brothers vibe.
Kind of scary, kind of sexy.
But I knew I just had
to nail it.
Alright, Mikey reading for the
role of Mikey. Let's hear it.
-Hey, Kyle, what are you
working on?
-That's a choice.
We'll be in touch, man.
-Okay.
-Might want to stick to
sketch comedy, bud.
So, yeah, the show tackles
current "SNL" drama.
But just like "Godfather 2,"
we also get to see Kyle's rise
to get here, his troubled past
growing up as a kid named Kyle.
I'll just play the kid.
Looking like an Irishman me
or something. Jesus.
But first we had to get the
thumbs-up from the big man.
Hey, Lorne.
"Serious Night Live,"
what do we think?
-Kyle, get out of my office.
-Lorne. Very biting wit.
So unlike normal sketches,
I had to pay about $85,000
of my own money --
the crew, the lights.
Had to pay for
the de-aging effects,
which turned out great.
-Let's make a video!
-Plus the drugs were
actually real.
And that was really expensive.
And the guys who sold them to me
sort of wanted to stick around.
Didn't love that,
but it's "Serious Night Live"
and we got Jake Gyllenhaal and
he totally brought his A-game.
-Whoa.
[ Laughs ]
-Kyle.
-Kyle offered me $40,000 cash
to act in this thing
and said it was
a legitimate crew.
I said yes 'cause I --
I don't know. I felt bad.
I don't really know the guy.
He's not really on the show
that much, right?
That's got to be tough.
-Chillin' like a Gyllenhaal.
Dude, great shoot.
You want to get drinks later?
-Oh, sorry, dude, I got to
rehearse for the show now.
-No worries.
Happy to drink alone.
Hey, any word if I'm in sketches
this week?
Sort of got F'd over
last Saturday.
-Uh, uh...
[ Telephone rings ]
-Well, that's a wrap on
"Serious Night Live."
I hope you enjoyed it.
I did spend a lot of money.
Obviously I'm almost 40.
And if -- if this doesn't take
off in a -- in a really big way,
there's probably no reason
for me to be in show business.
Or -- Or maybe even alive.
So...please just [bleep] tweet
about it.